is it true that the home office is now
subject to a judicial review over the
treatment of people at the manston
Immigration Center
uh well good evening I believe we have
received the initial contact for a
judicial review That's Not Unusual this
is a highly litigious area of policy but
of course as the minister responsible I
want to ensure that everything that we
do is conducted appropriately and within
the law and so in the week that I've
been in post I have tried to work night
and day to ensure that the manston site
is not just legally compliant but is a
Humane and compassionate place where we
welcome those migrants treat them
appropriately and then they leave
quickly to Alternative accommodation and
I'm very pleased to say this evening
that that's exactly the path that we're
on the number of people at manston has
fallen very substantially since the
weekend when we became aware of the
specific issues and got involved so
directly and I think we're on a path now
whereby within a matter of days assuming
we don't see very large numbers of
further migrants arriving a across the
channel I don't think that's going to
happen because we have good forecasts of
the weather and the other intelligence
that we have from northern France so I
expect that manston will be returned to
a well-functioning and certainly legally
compliant site very rapidly a matter of
days what's changed have you basically
tried to take over Zoella braven's brief
on this nope absolutely not we've been
working extremely closely together and
we've procured more hotels we have extra
support we've got brilliant officers
from border Force supported by
contractors and members of the Armed
Forces and we're processing the migrants
who are in the camp very quickly just on
the judicial review do you know if it's
been brought by I don't think I can
comment on on what might be ongoing
legal action they're not the only people
who are concerned uh this evening four
parliamentary committee chairs including
two conservatives have also written to
ask what the home office is doing to
address the conditions in munston they
worried in particular about the
conditions children are being held in
and the use of thoughts and physical
searches
you know being honest are you worried as
well well when I visited the camp on uh
Sunday I thought conditions were poor
and they needed to change rapidly that's
exactly well mainly because of the
number of people who are there remember
this facility was functioning acceptably
just a matter of weeks ago what's
changed is that we've had a very large
number of individuals across the channel
in small boats we would love to think we
can control that but of course that's
not entirely within our control and then
we had this terrible attack on Sunday by
this individual in Dover which caused us
to evacuate the almost 1 000 people who
are there and bring them immediately to
the site and that increased the numbers
from 3000 which was already too many to
four thousand where there was real
strain on the site I would just say
having been there that some of the
reporting is inaccurate there was
suggestions that there have been
diseases like diphtheria running wild in
the facility that's not correct to the
best of my knowledge there have been
four cases out of thousands of
individuals each of those cases We
Believe came into the site if you like
rather than being caught there there's a
very good medical facility when I was
there on Sunday there were two emergency
doctors there were paramedics and nurses
everybody is clothed they're fed they're
supported whilst they're there just as
you'd expect we you know we have values
as a country just because somebody's
chosen to come as a migrant we don't
want them to come in this way in small
boats but when they're here we'll treat
them appropriately and that's exactly
what we are doing and what we want to
get to uh in the coming days
um it's not just an issue that is about
this one Immigration Center though is it
it's about the strain on the system as a
whole and I just want to look now at a
chart showing the UK Asylum caseload it
effectively shows a rising number of
cases a class is still in process
without a full resolution
I mean is that really good enough no no
it's clearly not good enough and we have
a task to do now as I said I'm new in
the position suela Bravo and the Home
Secretary has only been in position for
six or seven weeks as well so together
we're going to work intensively to
reduce that backlog of cases we've
already put a significant amount of
extra resource behind this we have a
thousand people working on cases the
system is quite slow in this country
compared to some of our comparators like
France and Germany we think we can
improve productivity get people
processing the claims much faster but I
would just say that all of what we've
been talking about in the last week are
the symptoms of the problem the problem
is the fact that 40 000 people have
chosen to get into small boats to cross
the channel at the behest of dangerous
illegal criminal gangs and we are having
to try to cope with that and our
infrastructure was never designed for 40
000 people to come in small boats and to
land on our beaches will be saved at Sea
by border force rnli and the Royal Navy
with the best wool in the world they
would always put immense strain on our
system just to come back because you
said that they've chosen to come
if you're not from Hong Kong or Ukraine
or Afghanistan where there are specific
and bespoke legal ways to claim Asylum
or to claim an immigration claim to come
to the UK
how do you reclaim Asylum legally in the
UK because you only have to make the
claim when you're in the UK and yet
you're supposed to claim in the first
safe country you land in so it's
impossible isn't it no it's not great
when first firstly the numbers on the
schemes you just quoted are very large
so there's a hundred and fifty thousand
people in this country from Ukraine my
point is this is part of the reason why
well if you're from another country and
you feel that you are unsafe and you
want to claim yourself you finish that
point firstly the numbers are very large
from those places so the suggestion made
by some that the UK is not a big-hearted
generous country that's trying to play
its part in a global migration crisis is
not correct because we've issued a
hundred and thirty thousand Hong Kong
bno visas we've got 150 000 people here
under the homes for Ukraine scheme we
bought tens of thousands of Afghans to
the UK in addition to that there are
other safe and legal routes there's a
community sponsorship route which would
enable churches synagogues more
Community groups to sponsor individuals
to come here we have another scheme
where we work with the unhcr to enable
people who are in real distress often in
Refugee campus to say that the advice on
the website says you should apply when
you you should apply for Asylum when you
arrive in the UK and also says your
claim might not be considered if you
travel to the UK through a safe that's
right isn't it well I just I mean I I
think fundamentally that's the right
approach if you're in a safe country
like France that's where you should
claim Asylum I think the British public
are absolutely flabbergasted that there
are people in France who don't deem that
to be a safe country and put themselves
on there often their children as well in
immense danger to come to the UK you
know we want a system where we can
support people who are genuinely in
danger who are escaping War persecution
serious human rights abuses like we're
doing with Hong Kong Afghanistan and
Ukraine we do not want a system that
takes people literally out of the sea
often who are economic migrants and
prioritizes those over people well a
very substantial uh minority perhaps
more are economic migrants I mean if you
look at the example of Albania this year
a quarter of those people who've come in
small boats have come from Albania
Albania is a demonstrably safe country
it's a European country you've got Eddie
Rahman the prime minister of Albania
tonight saying you know don't talk
Albania down we're a safe country it is
not right
targeting Albanian albanians as the
cause of Britain's common border
problems makes the easy rhetoric but
ignores hard fact well I want to have a
constructive and productive relationship
with our Albanian friends that's
extremely that's extremely important but
it is correct that a quarter of people
who've come in small boats have come
from Albany this year and the ncar
National Crime organization has said
that a very significant proportion of
serious organized crime is emanating
from those individuals and again I think
there are millions of people who've been
watching your program this evening who
would think why on Earth is this country
spending thousands of pounds on hotels
on support for young men coming from a
safe country either we shouldn't do that
at all or we should prioritize that on
people in genuine danger such as an
Afghan interpreter and their family who
served the United Kingdom with honor and
distinction and those are the people we
should be working to support now we are
running out of time you're already um
you know close Ally of the Prime
Minister you're described in some
articles as his closest friend in
Parliament it feels like you're doing a
lot of heavy lifting if I may say on the
media rounds such as this evening on one
of the biggest challenging challenges
facing government are you the de facto
Home Secretary no no obviously not and
although though I am good friends with
Rishi sunai my longest friendship in
politics is Sue Ella Brotherman who I've
known for 20 years and I have huge
respect for her she is a great Home
Secretary and one of the things that she
is good at is articulating the genuine
concerns of the British public on this
issue so you haven't been put in
position as immigration Minister I guess
in case the ball did come she and us she
and I are working in lockstep on this
issue because the British public expect
their government to provide safe borders
and a fair and robust immigration system
and that's exactly what we intend to
deliver at warehouse time thank you
thank you